some deeply worrying things are as
always happening in the world however
bad it is we have an additional
complication what we call the news is
really a business that understands that
you can't make money by telling people
that things are on balance going to be
okay the point of the news is to make
money by scaring us and it does this
brilliantly but we need an antidote and
we can find it in a resource that's on
hand to remind us that difficulties
aren't new that troubles can be survived
and that it has in fact been a lot worse
than this before it's an antidote we
call history when political events seem
to have reached a new low we might for
example turn to the writings of the
ancient Roman historian Suetonius born
towards the end of the first century AD
gaius suetonius tranquillus was an
imperial administrator and chief
secretary to the Emperor Hadrian he was
the first historian to try to give an
accurate portrait of what the rulers of
the empire from Julius Caesar down to
Domitian had actually been like it's a
shocking story
Suetonius his book amounts to a
catalogue of extraordinary follies and
crimes of the first twelve men to rule
the Western world among them Julius
Caesar who emerges as a thief a liar an
egomaniac and a murderer Caligula a
notorious psychopath who to quote
Suetonius sent people down the mines or
threw them to wild beasts or confined
them in narrow cages where they had a
crouch or was sawn in half not for major
offenses but because they didn't
properly admire a show he had sponsored
at the circus or didn't refer with
sufficient respect to his genius
Suetonius tells us that the method of
execution he preferred was to inflict
numerous small wounds but avoiding all
major organs he often gave the command
make them feel they are dying then came
Nero of him we hear he dressed himself
in the skins of wild animals and
attacked the private parts of men and
women bound to stakes he wandered
through the streets at night randomly
murdering strangers and throwing their
bodies into the sewers
afterwards it was the turn of Vitelli
his ruling vices were gluttony and
cruelty he banqueted three or four times
a day and survived by taking frequent
emetics he used to give himself a treat
by having prisoners executed before his
eyes then it was time for Domitian at
the beginning of his reign we here
Domitian would spend hours alone every
day catching flies and stabbing them
with a needle sharp pen he wasn't any
nicer to his own people
those who atonia strides about grotesque
individuals who were also at the time
the most powerful people on the planet
reading him can leave one feeling
remarkably serene one might read him
tucked up in bed after news of the
latest election win the experience is
strangely reassuring because it's at
heart a narrative of resilience
Suetonius writes about earthquakes
plagues Wars riots rebellions
conspiracies but trails cooze terrorism
and mass slaughter considered on their
own
this might seem to be the record of a
society whose collapse must surely be
imminent but in fact Suetonius was
writing before and not after the most
impressive period of Roman achievement
which would come fifty years later under
the rule of the stoic philosopher and
Emperor Marcus Aurelius the disasters
that Suetonius catalogs were compatible
with a society heading overall towards
peace and prosperity
reading Suetonius suggests that it isn't
fatal for societies to be in trouble it
is in fact usual for things to go rather
badly in this respect reading ancient
history generates the opposite emotions
- scanning today's news events have been
much worse before and things were in the
end okay people behaving very badly is a
normal state of affairs there have
always been existential threats to the
human race and to civilization it makes
no sense and is a form of twisted
narcissism to imagine that our own era
has any kind of monopoly on idiocy by
reading Suetonius we enter unconsciously
into his less agitated and more stoic
responses he and history more generally
encouraged us to access what we need now
more than ever the less panicky more
resilient sides of ourselves
you